其他人：这个谱子好
Others: This sheet music is good.
其他人：我觉得很适合你
Others: I think it suits you.
Shure: 哪个
Shure: Which one?
其他人：我靠牛啊
Others: Wow, amazing!
其他人：来吧
Others: Let's do it.
其他人：这个行这个行
Others: This one works, this one works.
其他人：妈的你都不知道还有多少个快递
Others: Damn, you don't even know how many packages are left.
Tasha: 你自己来看嘛
Tasha: Why don't you come and see for yourself?
Tasha: 你来看来看来看
Tasha: Come on, take a look, take a look.
Tasha: 谢哥谢哥
Tasha: Thanks, bro, thanks, bro.
Tasha: 挑一件走
Tasha: Pick one and go.
其他人：ok
Others: Ok.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 你未来的梦想
Tasha: Your future dream.
Tasha: 就这个
Tasha: Just this.
Tasha: 这不是呀
Tasha: Isn't it?
Tasha: 哪有这么多
Tasha: Why are there so many?
Tasha: 这一一长串
Tasha: This is a long list.
Tasha: 这送给你女朋友
Tasha: This is for your girlfriend.
其他人：人工智能直接震惊了一个房间怎么能如此
Others: Artificial intelligence directly shocked a room, how can it be like this?
其他人：谢谢姐谢谢姐过几天来拿
Others: Thank you, sis, thank you, sis, I'll come to get it in a few days.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：你是我姐
Others: You are my sis.
Tasha: 还挺可爱的吧
Tasha: It's pretty cute, right?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 装饰完了
Tasha: Finished decorating.
Alice:真可爱
Alice: Really cute.
Tasha: 嘿
Tasha: Hey.
其他人：你知道那100左右ego币花了多少钱
Others: Do you know how much those 100 ego coins cost?
其他人：花多少钱150币
Others: How much? 150 coins?
其他人：400多 就为了创150币
Others: Over 400, just to make 150 coins.
其他人：如何使用
Others: How to use it?
其他人：他跟比特币是一个东西的
Others: It's the same thing as Bitcoin.
其他人：就是今天的活动赋予它价值
Others: Today's event gives it value.
Shure: （歌词）难忘今宵
Shure: (Lyrics) Unforgettable tonight.
Tasha: 你后面去三亚吗
Tasha: Are you going to Sanya later?
其他人：啊真的吗
Others: Ah, really?
Tasha: 真的呀
Tasha: Yes, really.
其他人：他要是愿意为我报销的话
Others: If he's willing to reimburse me.
其他人：我会义无反顾
Others: I would go without hesitation.
其他人：勇往直前
Others: Fearlessly.
Tasha: 这么好你们清华职务多吗
Tasha: That's so good, do you have a lot of positions at Tsinghua?
其他人：清华的话
Others: At Tsinghua?
其他人：嗯还行
Others: Hmm, it's alright.
Tasha: 我要做一个数据调查
Tasha: I need to do a data survey.
其他人：还行
Others: It's okay.
其他人：因为他他的西点就是非主要的教育区
Others: Because the western part is not the main educational area.
其他人：那边是原来圆明园的
Others: That used to be the Old Summer Palace.
Tasha: 那现在进去要预约吗
Tasha: Do you need an appointment to enter now?
其他人：嗯
Others: Hmm.
其他人：就是你可以在他的公众号预约
Others: You can make an appointment on their public account.
其他人：好像每天要限额吧提前开七天
Others: It seems like there's a daily quota, open seven days in advance.
其他人：就是今天开7天后
Others: So today, you can book for seven days later.
其他人：但其实周中一般都是不满
Others: But usually midweek, it's not full.
Tasha: 啊行
Tasha: Ah, okay.
其他人：但是五一肯定早满
Others: But on May Day, it's definitely booked early.
Tasha: 谁五一去我
Tasha: Who goes on May Day?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, hmm.
Tasha: 我肯定不会
Tasha: I definitely won't.
其他人：你就遥遥领先了
Others: You're way ahead.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 到时候我咨询咨询你
Tasha: I'll consult you when the time comes.
Tasha: 哪里植物多
Tasha: Where are there more plants?
其他人：西边是原来圆圆的园林
Others: The west side used to be a round garden.
其他人：小园林
Others: A small garden.
其他人：好毕设
Others: Good final project.
其他人：靠这是我毕设
Others: Damn, this is my final project.
其他人：平板还没写
Others: Haven't written anything on the tablet yet.
其他人：哇差MD翻译
Others: Wow, translate this, damn.
其他人：please translate this paragraph into Chinese
Others: Please translate this paragraph into Chinese.
其他人：你猜微信能写歌吗
Others: Do you think WeChat can write songs?
Tasha: 不知道啊杨老板
Tasha: I don't know, Jake.
Tasha: 哦苏诺
Tasha: Oh, Suno.
Tasha: 干什么
Tasha: What's up?
其他人：现在是什么环节
Others: What's the current session?
其他人：我马上要吃饭
Others: I'm about to eat.
其他人：我要饿死了
Others: I'm starving.
其他人：现在什么环节
Others: What's the current session?
Jake:吃饭
Jake: Eating.
Jake:对不知道是什么环节
Jake: Yeah, no idea what session it is.
Jake:应该是收眼镜
Jake: Should be gathering glasses.
Alice:1点多了
Alice: It's past 1 o'clock.
Jake:那个他
Jake: That guy...
Jake:他们人呢
Jake: Where are they?
Jake:他们在干嘛
Jake: What are they doing?
Alice:他们是不是在楼上
Alice: Are they upstairs?
Alice:先把它拿出来吧
Alice: Let's take it out first.
Alice:哇怎么这么多米饭
Alice: Wow, so much rice.
其他人：4散开来啊
Others: Scatter around.
其他人：4就是在干自己的事
Others: Just doing their own thing.
其他人：都在上面哎
Others: Everyone's upstairs.
其他人： 董叉叉不知道在干嘛
Others: Jack is doing who knows what.
其他人：给在玩乐器
Others: Playing musical instruments.
Jake:那不行给叫下来
Jake: No, call them down.
Alice:给你
Alice: Here you go.
其他人：这是你的吗
Others: Is this yours?
Alice:不是
Alice: No.
Alice:他们下来了吗
Alice: Are they coming down?
其他人：我已经喊过了来了一个
Others: I already called, one is here.
Shure: 吃饭不积极
Shure: Not enthusiastic about eating.
Shure: 思想有问题
Shure: There's something wrong with their mindset.
Jake:谢斌竹和刘帅呢
Jake: What about Xie Binzhu and Choiszt?
其他人：来了来了
Others: They're coming, they're coming.
其他人：吃饭了这个是不是椅子有点少
Others: Is there not enough chairs for eating?
Alice:站着吃
Alice: Just eat standing.
Jake:你收眼镜
Jake: Put away your glasses.
Jake:收眼镜别他妈玩了啊
Jake: Put away your glasses and stop messing around.
其他人：眼睛
Others: Glasses.
其他人：哎那几人在哪
Others: Hey, where are those guys?